at the heritage foundation we believe in
maintaining a strong national defense
and we are committed of course to the
defeat of terrorism at home and abroad
in the present international war however
most citizens have a limited concept of
the enemy
today's program is aimed at helping all
of us
better understand the religious
fanaticism we confront
its method of operation and the
fundamental threat
it poses to our western ideals our
featured speaker
melanie phillips is an award-winning
columnist for london's daily mail
educated oxford she trained as a
journalist on the evening echo
in himmelholm hempstead after a short
period
on new society magazine she joined the
the guardian
in 1977 and soon became its social
services correspondent
and social policy lead writer after a
stint as the guardians news editor
she started writing her column in 1987
taking it to the observer and then the
sunday times before starting to write
for the daily mail in december of 2001.
ms phillips also has written a play
traitors which was performed at dylan
hall in london in 1985
awarded the orwell prize for journalism
in 1996
she is the author of all must-have
prizes a study of britain's
educational and moral crisis the ascent
of
woman a history of the ideas behind the
female suffrage campaign
as well as other books her website
www.melaniephillips.com
collects many of her essays
a conservative by her opponents ms
phillips prefers to think of herself
as defending authentic liberal values
against the attempt to destroy western
culture from within
heritage is pleased to welcome our guest
for today melanie phillips
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed uh and uh
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen it's
a great pleasure
uh to be here um i'm going to talk to
you today about
britain's response to the threat of
islamic terrorism and extremism and by
way of introduction i should just
give you a couple of small caveats what
i am and what i am not
um i am merely a journalist and as you
may know journalists know
a little bit about everything and not
very much about anything
what i am not is an expert in terrorism
or counterterrorism
islam or indeed islamic groups
my particular interest
over the years as a journalist has been
in the
culture of great britain and the way in
which
uh western values are under threat and i
see the current situation of threat
from without very much in the context of
the threat from
within and it's in that context that i
propose to talk to you today and that is
indeed
more or less the subject of my book
i just want to start with the perception
that i have
that in this country americans tend to
think that britain is very much on
side and that is largely uh
because of our prime minister tony blair
who of course has been
extremely staunch in his support for
president bush in the war in iraq
and the war on terror but the idea that
because mr blair is
staunch britain is likewise is very far
from the truth mr blair has said he will
step down as britain's prime minister
as leader of the labour party before the
next general election
and the question uh that has to be posed
and which in the context of my remarks
you might care to ponder on is whether
whoever succeeds mr blair as britain's
prime minister
will remain as staunch a supporter of
america
in general and the war in iraq and the
war on terror
in particular in the light of the kind
of
cultural phenomena that i'm about to
describe to you
which are present in britain as a whole
i would suggest that britain although it
is
currently shoulder to shoulder with
america as we know
is in fact the weak link in the alliance
because of what i would describe as its
cultural
progressive cultural enfeeblement and
this is
extremely important to the united states
not simply because of its implications
for the future of the alliance and the
special relationship between britain and
america
but because of the possible knock-on
effects within america itself which i
hope will become
clear as i go on now what
exactly am i saying has happened well
very briefly and broadly
i would suggest that we are seeing in
britain nothing
other than an evisceration of british
national identity and values which has
created a cultural
and moral vacuum which is in the process
of being exploited
by radical and predatory islamism and i
would distinguish between islam and
islamism
islamism defined as that interpretation
of islam
which is militant and extremist which
sees
itself as in a state of perpetual war
with the west and wishes to colonize
and and destroy western values
now last year as you know london was
bombed by four homegrown muslim boys who
were
turnings who turned themselves into
suicide bombers and was succeeded by
another cell
who tries to do the same thing two weeks
later but whose bombs unaccountably all
failed to go
off now when these bombings happen
people were very shocked that homegrown
british boys could wish to murder
large numbers of their fellow british
citizens and they arrived at i think
the wrong conclusion uh they decided
that the only
possible reason for such behavior was
islamophobia in other words it was
our fault as a majority community that
we've been prejudiced against islam
discrimination
poverty or the war in iraq
the fact that these communities suddenly
became
came apparent that muslim communities
had failed to integrate was again blamed
on britain
for failing to integrate them by
allowing them to set up their own
muslim schools even though these bombers
had been to ordinary
integrated schools and have been to
ordinary universities
um so this was clearly absurd as a set
of excuses so
what was the cause of the bomber's
radicalization
well there are two sources of muslim
radicalization in britain
the first source came from um the middle
east
and uh the arab the arab world then
north africa
um and it took the form of fighters who
had seen off the soviets
in uh the war in afghanistan during the
eighties who had been radicalized to the
cause of jihad during that process
and had returned to their home countries
in the uh in north
north africa and the arab world as
radicals against their own governments
following which their governments had
probably thrown them out and where had
they found the most hospitable
home on the face of the earth it was in
britain
which for a number of reasons was
singularly inhospitable
to it were similarly hospitable to all
cameras
um so that was one uh one source and
these jihadists during the 1990s set up
shop in britain under the noses of the
british political and
uh security establishment and furnished
the most extraordinary procession of
terrorists
who went on to commit outrages worldwide
including zacharias musabi who was
jailed here last week
and whose mother said not without
justification that he was
only radicalized when he arrived in
london i think during the early 1990s in
order to pursue his studies
so why did the british security and
political establishment let this grow
under its nose in this way during the
1990s various reasons
its eye was very firmly off the middle
eastern
and arab bull the assumption was that
whatever radicalization was going on
over there through saudi
or harbism and so on was not actually
our problem we also
had strong links of a of an economic
kind
and other kinds with the arab world and
there was also what's been called the
covenant of security which was the
bargain that was entered into between
the security establishment in britain
and these radicals
that basically said we don't care what
you do elsewhere
as long as you don't blow us up we're
going to turn a blind eye
now why will be so hospitable why did
the radicals find that britain was so
remarkably congenial to to them
well partly it was because of our
excessive
deference to freedom of speech and the
pragmatic or you may say
cynical british view that today's
dissident
is tomorrow's potential prime minister
and therefore it does not
it's not as in britain's interests ever
to upset anybody
regardless of what he currently is doing
because tomorrow we will be entering
into some kind of treaty with him
so no questions asked excessive
deference to freedom of speech
tremendously congenial welfare benefits
no questions asked
whatever you do you get them and most
important during this period britain
just
lost control of its borders lost control
of its immigration
system uh due to a series of of cultural
and other
accidents and consequently uh nobody had
the faintest idea who was in the country
and who was out
so from the security point of view
complete nightmare you just didn't know
the intelligence service even if it was
looking for these guys had no idea who
was there and who wasn't there
now this loss of control over our
immigration system
goes to the heart of the kind of problem
that i'm
that i'm alluding to britain
has lost has lost belief
really in itself as a nation uh
and in furthermore uh in the idea of the
nation itself
the nation itself is seen as the cause
of all ills in the world from prejudice
discrimination
to war legitimacy resides instead in
supranational
institutions values and laws so
institutions such as the united nations
the european union
institutions like the international
criminal court and
values such as the doctrine of
international uh human rights
minority rights are considered to be
more legitimate because they are
not rooted in the particular the
particular is discriminatory by
definition the particular is rooted in a
majority
culture therefore majority culture is by
nature exclusivist and
therefore discriminatory therefore in in
essentially racist
the only non-discriminatory non-racist
therefore legitimate set of values must
be supranational
international not rooted in particular
so it's a real
nation-busting set of ideas that's
really got britain's intelligence here
by the throat and has done
for certainly the last 20 years i would
say
um this doctrine of what's called
britain human rights and i will put it
in quotations because i don't think
these are universal human rights of the
kind that you and i might
might might think were universal for
truly universal these are human rights
that are highly contingent
on a particular ideology and mediated by
a particular set of people called judges
i would prefer to call them minority
rights and this is really the coercive
arm through the law of the victim or
grievance culture
in which analysis of inestimable
importance to understanding what's
happened in
in britain in which minorities are
always conceived as the victims of the
majority and therefore they insist that
the majority exceed to their demands
represented as rights
otherwise the majority is to be vilified
as
racist sexist xenophobic muslim
islamophobic
or whatever now the english judiciary is
driven by
human rights doctrine and the english
judiciary has accordingly thwarted
every attempt by the government over the
last decade or more to enforce the
immigration rules and produce some kind
of order
to our immigration system
human rights more generally than on the
immigration has also been used as a kind
of
battering ram against the idea of
normative
social values in general in order to
give all kinds of minorities equal
rights
which means inescapably knocking the
majority values off their perch
so this kind of doctrine of radical
egalitarianism
has driven for example family breakdown
gay rights
rights for all kinds of minorities such
as gypsies transsexuals and so on
now the next associated great driver to
destroy
and remake the british nation and its
culture is multiculturalism which goes
along with
minority rights britain's demography is
changing quite dramatically
some six to seven million people are
expected to
be net immigration
amount net immigration over the next
three decades
83 of whom will be made up of immigrants
mostly from the third world
now in association with this uh
demographic change
has come the phenomenon that the
majority culture is seen as illegitimate
because it's racist and inhospitable and
instead all cultures must be equal
which as i said is the great driver
against the majority culture
so at the same time you've got this
tremendous demographic change you have
multiculturalism
which seeks to negate the idea of the
nation so instead of doing
integration which is what we've always
done in the past when we're faced with
immigrants
who have thus enhanced the nation
because they have been integrated and
have brought
their own thing to enhance the culture
which they share instead of doing
integration we now do disintegration in
every sense
what it means is that those immigrants
who come in because
they want to assimilate and integrate
because they value
what they conceive of as british
identity and values
they find that britain no longer knows
what that identity and those values are
and
insofar as it does know doesn't like
them very much and is trying
its best to disintegrate so
schools for the last couple of decades
have no longer taught british political
history
instead everyone's told their own
culture is what matters so
it means that immigrant children are
left in ignorance of the society into
which they wish to integrate and
therefore cannot do so because they have
no
purchase on it because they don't know
about it and it means that indigenous
children have no pride in their own
culture are taught instead to despise it
and end up uh knocking the daylights out
of immigrants as a result which is not
really
very surprising not a very sensible way
of running a country in terms of more
general social values everyone's told
make up make them up as they go along
because morality has been
privatized and alongside this has come a
kind of assault
on christianity multiculturalism
pays lip service to equality but when it
comes to equality i'm afraid the
founding value of our british society
which is the judeo-christian
set of values uh isn't treated as equal
at all
indeed uh when it comes to
minority uh uh sorry the the funding of
voluntary groups uh christian groups
find that they are denied state funding
because they are held to be
exclusive and discriminatory why after
all these christian groups
reach out to all faiths and none they're
exclusive and discriminatory because
they're
christian because they're actually
promulgating christian doctrine that is
not allowed
so minority rights multiculturalism
equality it's all a fiction
it's actually an assault on the majority
culture
now when it comes to young muslim men
this has left
many of them absolutely stranded and
with
lethal consequences for the rest of us
quite apart from the radicals who came
into britain during
the uh 1990s as i've described who came
mainly from north africa
and the middle east we've had a separate
stream of muslim immigration
which is largely from um the indian
subcontinent pakistan
bangladesh who came in into our northern
mill towns mainly
uh from really the 1970s onwards
um and uh
it's these young men who have been
really stranded
they or their families came from
extremely poor areas of
pakistan and bangladesh and what no one
noticed at the time was that those areas
were themselves being radicalized very
heavily
by uh in terms of the islamic religion
uh in terms of the saudi uh wahhabism
which
colonized as it were pakistan and
because these people are very poor
um and not properly integrated into
britain they remain and because that
many of them
thought they would actually go back to
where they came from they maintained
very close links with their host
community and consequently the
radicalization that went on in pakistan
was transferred to britain institutions
were set up in britain uh
unknown below the official radar which
preached extremism
and radicalized young muslim men without
anybody realizing it and taught hatred
of the west
now these young men who grew up and are
growing up
are very often not religious at all
um they live pretty lives which are
pretty indistinguishable from
non-muslim men um they're into
everything
sex drugs rock and roll the lot they've
rejected the village life of their
parents
on the one hand on the other hand they
are simply beset by the licentiousness
and decadence
of britain where all self-discipline has
completely broken down
and in particular they are beset
literally physically by young women who
sexually throw themselves up
so on the one hand they're being told
that this is absolutely forbidden
absolute sin and goes against their
whole notion of of them of the dignity
of their culture
and on the other hand it's in their
heads because even though they may
reject it the freedom license
is a very seductive thing
and they can't easily get rid of it
so the confusion this sets up and the
the kind of cultural dislocation and the
i suppose the anguish that it sets up at
some level
makes them a particularly easy prey for
radical
islamists who are not just the imams in
the mosques but they are people like
peripatetic youth workers
prison councillors
youth organizers who go around the
campuses the campuses in britain are a
prime site of radicalization and they
recruit these young men
to extremism and some of them to the
actual physical
jihad
now all this
went on pretty well unremarked and when
it did become remarked
as i've indicated already britain came
up with a whole
set of excuses and alibis to avoid
facing up to the fact this is actually
rooted in religion
britain thinks if we say this thing is
rooted in religion then we are
demonizing all muslims
which we don't want to do now
it would be quite wrong to demonize all
muslims and one has to be very careful
that one doesn't do so but it is a
complete non-sequitur
to say this would demonize all muslims i
mean as far as i can see and i'm not an
expert on this this is a
predicated most at its most uh uh
conservatively
this is an ideology which is rooted in
the religion it's because in the sense
that it is a particular interpretation
of the religion
which happens sociologically speaking to
be
mainstream at the moment in the muslim
world
it does not mean that all muslims sign
up to it on the contrary the
vast majority of people across the world
who are the victims of it
are muslims but equally it's otio's to
say
that it is not related to religion if
you say that you simply don't understand
what this thing is and you are denying
it's essential it's essential aspect
but britain's gone down this road and
it's decided to adopt the path of least
resistance it's too difficult
to identify this thing as being rooted
in religion
it's too difficult because people are
very frightened in this multicultural
uh uh uh
universe that we are living in they're
very frightened of being accused of
racism
or islamophobia being nasty to religions
and so on so forth
and so it's easier to blame ourselves
it's easy to say
it's our fault it's because they are not
being integrated by us properly it's
because they are
victims of our prejudice and so on and
that means
that britain's establishment has instead
of facing this
squarely and saying to muslims
which i think they should say you're
welcome here you're free to practice
your religion
what you're not free to do is to
practice and preach islamism which is
an attempt against the state
and we will welcome the one but we will
prohibit
prohibit the other instead of that
britain's taken the path of least
resistance
and it's basically brought into the
muslim the radical muslim narrative
which inverts
aggressor and victim right and
wrong and this has meant that britain's
establishment has posed
no systematic challenge whatsoever to
the lies that muslims are told
principally about america is iraq and
israel
the lies which feed the hatred of the
west
on the contrary these tropes which are
false
have been increasingly shared by the
mainstream indigenous
population in britain which has in an
extraordinary alliance brought together
left and right the left start from the
position they are
anti-america anti-capitalist the third
world
is always the victims of the first
always the victims of capitalism
therefore the third world can never do
wrong
so when 9 11 happened america had it
coming to it it's that
way of thinking that's the left
the right by which i mean the equivalent
of your red states actually
uh which are very very different in
britain
this is how it plays out on the right
the right don't buy all the stuff about
the left about capitalism
the rights say the red state right says
we're an island if the world
if we don't defend the world then the
world has no quarrel with us
the world is a foreign place we know
nothing about the world
it's full of crazy people as long as we
don't upset them
why should they care about us
furthermore
um we don't much like america
uh america was very slow coming to our
raid in the last war
we don't like this person who's running
america
we don't like the fact that he thinks
that god speaks to him we think this is
really very dangerous we don't like
irrationality
we're british we are empirical we don't
believe anything unless we
see it no weapons mass destruction found
in iraq
it follows there were never any
followers we were told a lie
we don't believe anything unless we see
it what is
the cause of these boys blowing
themselves up
it must be something terrible has
happened to them it must be they've been
dispossessed of their land
it must be they are the victims of
poverty and persecution
it must be something concrete it is
these concrete geopolitical grievances
that are driving them to this
it is a kind of super protest movement
that's what al qaeda is
so that's where the rights coming from
so the right and the left
join up like that you cannot put a
cigarette paper between them
in their views about israel america
and iraq and the thinking goes as
follows
of the red states equivalence
america had it coming to it why because
the cause the real cause of the global
jihad
is israel if israel had not denied the
palestinians their state
these muslims would not be crazy and
would not wish to blow us up
america made itself a target simply
because it uncritically supports israel
we in britain would never have been a
target had not our
prime minister been president bush's
poodle and gone along with america in
its alliance
so the fact that we are now under threat
from the jihad
is the fault of blair and bush
and the war in iraq and the ongoing
ampas
in israel that's the analysis
and on top of that you've got the kind
of cultural confusion caused by this
moral inversion i was talking about
before victim culture which
confuses victim and victimizer so that
you have a whole procession of british
worthies from the prime minister's wife
downwards
who have said that they sympathize with
palestinian suicide bombers
and if they were in that position
possibly they too would behave like that
and nobody lit sleep up leaps up and
down and says this isn't a poor thing to
say people say yeah yeah they got a
point
so the result of all that is that
there's a general
pandemonium in britain uh
that uh which combines with the
distrust of mr blair on the whole
variety of other
reasons domestic reasons people don't
trust him they think that he tells lies
all the time
dislike of president bush the continuing
war in iraq are the terrible scenes that
we see
the fact that no wmd were found all this
makes them think we were all taken to
war on a line the sooner blair departs
and takes his support from america with
him
the better so whoever comes after him
that is the constituency they are going
to be addressing
mr blair is on his own against his party
and against his country he is absolutely
isolated
and i have no idea what will follow him
i can't tell you the answer to this
question
but nevertheless i'm describing is the
kind of situation in britain as a whole
to which any politician will be paying
very close attention now the result of
all this is that britain keeps getting
it wrong
when uh mahmoud ahmadinejad recently
ratcheted up his
nuclear defiance a few weeks ago
forgotten precisely what he said that
you you know the general sort of thing
he's been saying
the response to britain was absolute
horror not because ahmadinejad
might now get the bomb but because that
america
might now be more likely to attack him
there's america that was seen as a
threat
not iran when the danish cartoon jihad
erupted across the world the british
media
stood out from the rest of europe in
refusing to republish these drawings
which was being done in
various countries in europe in defense
of western values at a demonstration
outside the danish embassy by islamists
police arrested not those people holding
banners saying
behead the infidel but they tried to
arrest those who protested
at the display of those banners
the attitude of the whole governing
class is very deeply alarming
uh the same instinct for appeasement
which was on display during the growth
of londonistan during the 1990s
is still the case the problem is that
the british political
and security establishment will not
accept will not acknowledge that the
root cause of this is religion
so we had the surreal scene after the
london bombings last july
in which let me remind you four
home-grown muslim boys tried to blow up
and did in fact blow up
blow up the london the london subway a
senior
london police officer went on tv and
said the word in my book the words
islamic and terrorism do not go together
remarkable
[Music]
the security establishment therefore
realizes that we're up against something
new but they conceive it as a kind of
new and more terrible and more lethal
type of the kind of terrorism
they've always known so it's the kind of
the mechanics are different
but the motivation is the same is
geopolitical it's a protest against
geopolitical
grievances like palestine or iraq
and so their strategy is to appease it
because britain does appeasement um and
the the government strategy to combat
extremism is therefore to tackle the
what they call underlying causes well
i'm all in favor of tackling underlying
causes at all times the problem is how
they define the underlying causes
and they define it they define them as
foreign policy i.e iraq
and our support for israel
discrimination and poverty
so instead of challenging the lies of
the grievance culture
at the heart of the problem our
government in britain is choosing to
endorse that very culture so it's asking
itself in an agonized fashion
is it listening to muslims enough is it
communicating the right messages of
uh up to and about muslims that they're
a religion of peace and they don't do
violence
and should our stance in britain on the
middle east and other foreign policy
issues possibly change
to meet these concerns and the fact that
some of these answers are coming as no
should not blind us to the fact that
these there's a problem here because the
questions are being asked
our establishment now draws if it goes
further than this it draws a
complete line between al-qaeda
on the one hand and the muslim
brotherhood on the other al-qaeda bad
muslim brotherhood can be bad but not
necessarily
they don't do violence intrinsically
they're just religious not cases
and we should just respect that that's
fine the fact that there's a continuum
along which people sit at varying stages
and that continuum
at the end of it is a kind of conveyor
belt to violence
and that if you teach people the west
thinks
israel is an apartheid state racist and
there's
screwing the palestinians america is
screwing the west the jews are screwing
america
if you teach them all that you it's not
rocket science you teach them hatred
and some of those people are going to
end up as terrorists and even if they
don't
end up as terrorists they're not very
good citizens in the middle
of that continuum but no british
establishment thinks this is very
unsophisticated reasoning
the really sophisticated approach is to
divide and rule which of course
britain's always done
so in order to siphon off
impressionable vulnerable young muslim
men from the danger of
being sucked in by al-qaeda you throw
them
into the arms of the brotherhood which
will give them a sense of identity
and religious belief and will resolve
all their internal contradictions and
keep them out of mischief
to me this is completely mad but that is
the policy
and so as a result we've had the surreal
situation in which the prime minister
set up
a network of committees to advise him on
a network of committees of muslims to
advise him on how to combat
islamist extremism and lo and behold he
stuffed it or he didn't stop any civil
servants
stuffed it stuff these committees with
the brotherhood
and what was the react what was the
result of that well
the committee's first uh decision was to
rush out a statement
demanding the end of holocaust memorial
day on the basis that
it was quite wrong just to memorialize
uh the
nazi holocaust and ignore the holocaust
committing
being committed by israel in palestine
and number of other
anti-muslim holocausts that was their
hordurve
and for their main course they served up
a final set of recommendations which
said
yes there is a problem that muslims are
committing terrorism
the reasons are foreign policy
islamophobia
discrimination kindly sought all those
things out
that was the prime minister's committee
on on advising him
against how to how to combat islamist
terrorism uh government thinks it's
using
uh islamist extremists in a very
sophisticated and clever
strategy in order to defeat terror
i in my view they are being used by
these terrorists
by these extremists who are playing them
for suckers if you
ride a tiger you must expect to get
eaten
i would finally just say a few words
about why i think america should be
particularly concerned about this
um there are obvious reasons and less
obvious reasons the obvious reasons are
as i've said before we don't know
i can't really tell you what's going to
come after mr blair and whether the
alliance therefore with britain
will be as strong as it is at the moment
and that must be of some concern
that's the first problem the second
problem i think is more subtle and more
dangerous
um it's a cultural problem uh
britain um maybe
now a small country and its military
power may be relatively minor compared
with the
might of america but it punches very
much above its weight in the cultural
sense it remains a leader of the
english-speaking world
britain is after all where the concepts
of
liberty rule of law and democracy were
first
forged and britain i would suggest is
now
busily deconstructing the values that
created
those concepts which we all hold dear
which are common
to the free world if britain goes down
this road
without stopping goes further down this
road of kind of uh
cultural submission if you like cultural
negation
self-negation then i think that
its impact is going to be very
considerable on america and on the free
world
for these reasons first of all it will
play upon the kind of tendencies you
have here which are of a similar kind uh
it's a different situation here from
britain and here you have culture wars
in britain we've had a route here you've
got a fight back
in britain we have no institutions to
fight back here you have
institutions like this you have talk
radio you have the conservative bloggers
and so on
to provide a kind of alternative
discourse uh to the mainstream
intelligentsia in british in britain we
have no
alternative we have only tiny number of
alternative thinking think tanks which
are
completely disregarded and there is
there is no real challenge to the
hegemony
of the uh mindset of the left which
dominates
our intelligentsia but you have these
tendencies here
in your media within your media in your
political class and particularly on your
campuses
and while as i said you know there are
significant differences between your
culture
and britain's i think that if britain
really does go down this road
without stopping then the kind of
knock-on effect because of the kind of
cultural exchange
will empower and exacerbate
these tendencies that are in america and
more broadly
just as you know britain as i say
invented these values in the first place
if it disinvents them that's gonna have
a much broader
knock-on effect i think in in in the
free world
uh these these tennis i'm talking about
are in europe
variously i mean they're not the same
they all play a bit differently
um but some or all of them are there and
uh as i say britain punches above its
cultural weight and
uh britain's influence in this is is
very great
um and so uh i think it should be of
great alarm to america
um i think america should wise out to
what's happening in britain
and i think it would be very helpful if
concerned folk in america at all kinds
of levels
jumped up and down a lot about this and
started speaking about it in public
because one of the problems in britain
is that no one speaks about it for all
the reasons i've been
i've been saying a lot of people who are
very well disposed
and perfectly sensible because they're
busy and they're ignorant
they haven't got a clue what's going on
um so
it will be very helpful to have this
amplified
from our greatest ally friend and
protector
across the atlantic i'll leave it there
and i'm very happy to take questions
[Applause]
and i'm going to ask the first one is
there any hope
anybody out there speaking on behalf of
this question
in britain to hinge any
future change on uh there are people who
are concerned in britain
they don't have much of a voice because
it's very difficult to get heard
the media is hostile to the point that
which you can't actually
very easily um say this in public or
write this in public
or broadcast it
the publishing trade is very very
reluctant
to publish it um so
it is it is tricky but i think that
the way through this as i say if if an
outside
well-intentioned body such as the united
states or people in the united states
were to start
putting it onto a kind of international
agenda then people in britain would have
no
option but to start engaging with it if
only to say this is completely untrue
but at least there would then be a
debate
the issues would start to be aired
we will take questions we just need to
wait for the mic i'll start
at the back my name's kay mccuro and i
work in a law firm here in the district
and
miss phillips i get your daily diary and
i want everybody to know about it
um i had this morning's paper there was
an article
that was very brief about the
deportation of a
radical muslim named abu kataba
that they were trying to uh to get out
of the country
however the government is being
wishy-washy what do you think will
happen with that
well um by
past experience not a great deal
this story of abu qatada is astonishing
abu qatada is by as far as i can see
from
from various intelligence agencies
around the world possibly the single
most
important jihadist in britain and in
europe
many many plots are traced back to him
in london
he was the imam at the famous or
infamous finsbury park mosque which
radicalized
very very large numbers of young muslims
in britain
he is a truly important terrorist
and yet it took a very very long time
for anything
to be done about him at all i mean he
was left at liberty for many many
years and as you say there is now
a tremendous fight to stop him from
being
extradited to jordan i think it is
over the last decade or more um
the story of londonistan was that
country after country requested and
implored britain to extradite a whole
set of
people like abu qatad but not as
dangerous not as important
and fell foul of our judicial system
basically
um our judiciary because of its
obsession with human rights
will not allow anyone to be deported to
a country
where there is a risk that people in
general
might be ill-treated by their judicial
or non-judicial system
and tortured you don't have to prove to
a british judge
a british court that this particular
individual because of his particular
circumstances
is likely to be tortured you only have
to show
that jordan does not have the kind of
civil liberties outfits that we have in
britain for the judges to say that's it
we are not going to send him there
because we will therefore be sending him
to be tortured
uh british courts will not extradite to
america for the same reason
because death penalty guantanamo bay
can't do that so we're paralyzed
now after the july bombings happened mr
blair
got up and said with a particular and he
was
obviously particularly referring to our
judiciary
he said the rules of the game are now
changing and everybody said
ah at last we're going to have some
sense
and the judge's heads are going to be
not together and within
a few days or weeks the senior judiciary
rose up and said we will resist this
we will not be told what to do we adhere
to
human rights which are over and above
anything that a government wants to do
and that we will lose the war on terror
which we think is much exaggerated
if we sacrifice our british liberties
um uh uh um if we do that
then we've actually lost the war on
ourselves
um and so we have a kind of impasse
where the government in my view
mr blair talks tough in this way the
rules of the game are changing but what
he will not do
is undo uh the legislation which allows
the judges
to take this position uh mr blair came
to power
committed to a radical agenda as defined
by himself
which was very much centered around the
whole doctrine as i've
laid out to you before of universalism
universal human rights
um he uh did not sign up britain
to the international treaty of human
rights
the convention that was done a long time
ago but what he did do what his
administration did is almost its first
move
was to repatriate or rather bring home
that
that that that convention and and
enshrine it
in english law and that has created a
tremendous head of steam behind the
whole rights culture and has really
given the judiciary a role which um
previously wanted to play and now it
really is playing as a kind of
alternative
power base to the government in many
ways although it wouldn't
it wouldn't agree with my analysis for a
second but that's in my view what's
happened
so mr blair has done that and if he
really wanted to change the rules of the
game
he would repeal his human rights act and
he would do various other things
of the same kind of of of
of the same nature but he won't do that
because this is typical of mr blair
he talks the talk he won't walk the walk
another question
correspondent of daily times lahore
pakistan
miss philip so what are you suggesting
should be done
should all the muslims british muslims
be
thrown out should immigration be stopped
should
what exactly are you suggesting should
be done well
the position that i hold is easily
caricaturable along the lines that you
are suggesting
and i have gone out of my way in my book
to make clear that i'm not suggesting
anything of the kind
that the principal victims of this
across the world are muslims
and that in my view some of the victims
of this in britain are
truly reformist muslims who say that the
ground is being
cut from under their feet by the
appeasement of extremism
being practiced by the government and
the establishment
what i'm suggesting is that britain
the british establishment should give a
very clear message which says as i said
before
which says to muslim immigrants or to
the muslim communities in britain
you are more than welcome here
immigrants are welcome here they enhance
the life of the nation
muslims are welcome you are free and
welcome to practice your religion
we have no problem with that at all
we're a tolerant country
um and that is fine but we will not
tolerate islamism
like all minorities muslims must accept
the terms of settlement of minorities
into britain a bit different from
america perhaps but this is how it is in
britain
it's a very strong majority culture
which is the kind of overarching
framework of citizenship
to which everyone all minorities must
subscribe otherwise the society
fragments
within that overarching set of values
people are free to practice their own
religion their own culture
where those values conflict with the
overarching
framework then the settlement has always
been
the understanding has always been that
the minority values give way and the
majority
values win what i'm saying the british
government should be saying is
we will not accept this demand backed by
menace
that that's no longer the case and that
whatever minority demands there are the
majority has to give way
that we won't accept so another is you
draw a complete line between
the practice of a religion islam on the
one hand which is fine
people are welcome to do that they're
valued members of the community
and on the other hand the people who
practice what i would call islamism
which is the politicized version of that
which says that the
values of the west must be overthrow
over overturned and subjugated that we
will not put up with
and so the practical consequences of
that are
that we have to for example look at what
uh
muslim institutions are teaching um if
they're teaching sedition
if they're teaching the overthrow of the
west we must say that is not acceptable
we must take the appropriate measures
against that
um
and to you know to to say that that sort
of singles out
uh or demonizes a whole community i
think is
is a false um this is a kind of moral or
intellectual blackmail if you like in
it in itself and it's simply not true
and there are other
ins there are other um uh instances i
give um
in in my book in which um
i think that we also have a big problem
and i think we share this problem with
the united states
what we're facing is not terrorism as
we've
always understood it to be nor is it war
as we've always understood it to be
because war is conceived between states
we face something which is between the
two of which we have no
adequate description we certainly have
no
adequate institutions uh
to deal with it and you know it's beyond
me i mean i'm
i'm a journalist there are others who
are much better than i are devising
the structures that we need all i think
is that we do need a different set of
structures which recognize that we're in
a kind of new situation
which in which the structures of our
criminal justice system don't apply
and the structures of our system in
dealing with war uh
don't apply i think this is one of the
problems of guantanamo bay it fell
very very heavily into this vacuum uh
and uh you know with the consequences
that we would that we've all seen the
controversy that's
that's that's that's uh surrounded it so
uh the third thing i would say is that
we have to as a host community
in britain um uh realize
that uh one of the problems is that we
are no longer
upholding ourselves as a nation with a
majority culture
that we should go back to the premise
that immigrants are welcome and we will
integrate them
under the rubric that i said before that
there should be an overarching
sense of citizenship and national
identity within which people are free to
practice
their own cultures but to do that we
have to restore in britain
our sense of our own national identity
our belief in it
our values uh but the the the the value
that we that we that we that we give to
it and that
in turn means addressing all kinds of
things like our relationship with the
european union
like our subscription to international
value systems such as human rights it
means radically rethinking some of the
things that we've
we've really come to accept as kind of
normal and multiculturalism
multiculturalism you know we
if if we really do think that we're a
multicultural country well the game
really is up and
you know uh all minorities will have
equal status with each other and then
everyone will just fight with everybody
else for supremacy
and that's the way society fragments
completely
i think that's social suicide i don't
think it's in anyone's interest for that
to happen
so britain has to re-establish its sense
of of of itself
as as a majority in other words
re-establish the rules of the game as
previously applied
in which we're a tolerant nation we
welcome immigrants we welcome muslims
but everyone has to play to the rules of
the game which is that there is majority
culture
which asserts itself but which within
which there is tolerance
and there is religious freedom
washington independent writers you
mentioned the breakdown
in immigration in britain at one point i
thought i heard you mentioned
20 years of school of what was being the
start of the problem
would you see the leadership of margaret
thatcher as part of the problem
in what you see as a breakdown and what
role is free trade and market capitalism
and its promoters cost in creating
problems with immigration in britain
um well the problem certainly preceded
this labour government in 1997
they inherited chaos in our asylum
system which was being grossly abused
under the previous conservative
administration of john major
which was uh which dated from the early
1990s
um i'm i'm not aware of our such a
fundamental breakdown happening under
uh margaret thatcher's tenure
um although i would say of her tenure
that
in my view and i held this view at the
time and i i still think it she was
particularly um taken up with matters of
economics and tended to think that
everything
had an economic um dimension
and that everything could be sold by the
application of any kind of
economic principle of the market and i
think that um
she did not pay attention to what was
happening kind of under her
radar which was a deconstruction of the
culture
which was preceding a pace in the
schools at that time
during the 1980s she woke up to it in
the late 1980s in 1988
she produced an education bill to try
and stop the rot which actually for a
variety of reasons which are
i can tell you know is it is literally
another book which i wrote
um uh made the problem infinitely worse
but that's that's another source of
grief
um in terms of immigration um
i don't recall it being quite such a
problem um
i mean this was again she
she despite her anti-european image and
rhetoric
actually signed the country up to
european integration
to a much greater extent than we
previously had
and certainly in my view one of the
consequences of that
is the sort of open borders
premise of the eu
which has certainly exacerbated the
the problem but as we know there's been
a tremendous movement from
south to north more generally for which
obviously she can't be held responsible
and nor can the european union itself
be held entirely responsible um
but so in terms of the breakdown of
asylum
which precipitated our crisis in
immigration i think that was
really driven by the tremendous movement
from south to north
uh which we then couldn't cope with
because we
you know immigration in britain is a
neurologic issue nobody
talks about it nobody deals with it it's
considered completely taboo
in case you're considered racist so uh
and one of the consequences of that is
that the relevant ministry in britain
which deals with immigration
is staffed by people who are very low
quality and ministers are very low
quality because it's so much down the
political pecking order
so you have this this potential um
difficulty of this huge movement of
people
uh you have wholly inadequate uh
administrative class
which can't deal with it overlaid by a
refusal even to talk about the problem
um which so i think it got going after
after after she left office
sam walker i'm with the heritage
foundation what
what do you see as being sort of behind
all of this
i mean there seems to me that there that
this is
like one of the consequences of a sort
of a
very fundamental loss of confidence
on the part of western culture in
general not just
britain that's why you're over here
talking to americans because we're part
of
what's happening as well and it seems to
me that
if we had the confidence that we used to
have i
you know i don't even think that it's
the case that the islamists
would i mean i don't think they would be
doing what they do i don't even think
they would have the courage to even try
what they're doing i think they see
something and i just wonder
what you have to say about any of that
well that's very much my
my view i mean i think that um
the isla the islamists are entirely
correct
in their analysis of the west uh
i think they got america slightly wrong
because i think that they lumped america
with europe
but in general i think they're correct
that the west is gripped by
decadence literally a decay in its
belief in itself
now there are many reasons for this
decadence
one way of looking at it is to say
well there are many reasons and and they
play differently in different countries
in britain
one of the main drivers in my view has
been the collapse of religious
belief that's not clearly it's clearly
not the case in america
but in britain the church has been the
forefront of
caving in to
social nihilism whereas here
one of your main reasons why you have a
fight going on is because your churches
are
still very very strong
um so that's one reason
another reason is and perhaps this does
link
america with britain it's almost
a kind of um
i mean i think t.s eliot wrote about
this how a liberal society finally
disappears up its own backside
it's the kind of apotheosis of
liberalism
that you know as a society becomes so
open
and makes such a fetish or its openness
it's destroyed by the openness
so you know we fetishize freedom of
speech
we find it extraordinary difficult to
stop people from saying what they want
to say
if people then say the west should be
destroyed we say
okay it's extreme but nevertheless he's
right to say it and
in a society like ours and a democracy
you have somebody else saying no the
west should not be destroyed and that's
fair okay that's one view
um then there's a whole business of
religion liberal society
our liberal settlement in the west post
the enlightenment
was to privatize religion and to say
that religion
should be tolerated okay there are many
wrinkles to this some religions you know
some minorities have not been tolerated
some religions have been not
tolerated but anyway broadly that was
the settlement it became private
distinction between public and private
space whatever was going on in private
space was
off limits as far as the public sphere
was concerned
that was tolerance if the public sphere
got involved in religion as part of the
private space it was oppressive
now we all think this you think it more
than we do
um even this gets in the way
when you have religion being used as a
political movement
against the west so in a way you can see
this as a kind of uh
literally you know the sort of
attesting to destruction uh liberal
values
and it poses an enormous dilemma for us
because you know this argument is going
on with our judiciary in britain and
there's not a silly argument these
judges saying
if we destroy the values that we've all
held dear
um then in in order to protect ourselves
from terrorism then we will destroy our
culture
and there are two ways of looking at it
one way is to say yes
you're completely correct because if our
values go we have nothing then to defend
the other way is to say you're
completely mad because if you don't
accept that we need to defend ourselves
you would have the values in the first
place
both are right this is the dilemma
so this is a major problem that's one
set of that's i think that's just a kind
of fundamental problem and then
overlaying that you have the sort of
loss of confidence
that comes from a variety of things
coming together in britain
the loss of confidence in the nation was
driven by the end of colonialism
the end of empire the uh
the new kindergentler tolerant society
after the second world war which said
authoritarianism was the route to mass
murder and therefore
authority was very suspect a confusion
of the two
and therefore the authority that we had
had in the empire
we misused because we kept down the
autonomous
uh individualistic cultures that wanted
free expression and all that
it's a whole sort of set of of thinking
that that took us down
a road to say actually our history
was really awful and there's nothing
that the west did which was in any way
good and so we have in britain we have
this extraordinary situation where our
archbishop of canterbury are
the leader of our established church got
up not long ago and delivered a sermon
in which he apologized for the export of
christianity to the third world
because it was an imposition on the
god-given right of all peoples
to be equal in their cultures
you don't have that in the states in
terms of your church but you do have it
elsewhere this whole
multicultural set of beliefs so this is
the way we unravel a culture
this creates a kind of paralysis so i
think the question you ask
it's not an easy question to answer it's
very complicated it
would require yet another book i'm sure
um
but it's somewhere in you know in that
territory
okay thank you melanie
[Applause]
we will let uh melanie join us up here
at the stage for signing her books if
you would like to come up and speak with
her further that's
welcome too we do thank you for your
kind attention we are adjourned